[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا نحيكم
الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده ابرز
ملفات اليوم في ملفاته هذا المساء حملتونا
امنيه وعسكريه
الامن تطلق الرصاص الحياه على المحتاجين
فهل قمع طهران سيخمد انتفاضه الشعب ام
سيزيدها اشتعالا في ملفنا الثاني لاول مره
ابنه زعيم القوريه
وكيف سيرد عليها اليابان والغربه وفي
الملف الثالث بعد التسريحات والاستقالات
والقرارات التي تبدو منتخب ايطاليا
سيبقى تويتر حيا بدماء وفطر مختلف ام ان
ادارته الجديده ستقضي عليه
[موسيقى]
وضع خطير للغايه تعيش في مدينه مهابات
شمال غرب ايران نتيجه الهجوم المكثف
للقوات الامنيه والعسكريه بالاسلحه
الثقيله ضد محتاجين خرجوا للمشاركه في
جنازه كمال احمد بور الذي قتل برصاص الامن
المدينه مقطوعه او مقطوع عنها والانترنت
وسط استغاثه الاهالي طلبا للمساعده هذا هو
كان حذر الحزب الديمقراطي والكردي من
الوضع المقلق في المدينه
وانها تحمل رمزيه خاصه كونها شهادات اعلان
جمهوريه ما بعد الكرديه عام
1946 التي استمر واحدا كما نبه الحزب الى
ان الحرس الثوري يحشد عناصره للهجوم على
المنطقه
لحقوق الانسان اعلنت ان النظام الايراني
اخرى في كردستان وطلبه الجميع
شعبه الايراني الى ساعدت اهالي مهباد
وسنندرج ايضا عاصمه اقليم كردستان غربيه
البلاد اتت تلك الدعوات فيما لا يزال
اطلاق النار يسمع في ارجاء مهابات كما لا
تزال عشرات المدن الكرديه تنتفض بي وجه
سلطات منذ مقتل الشباب مهسا اميني منتصف
سبتمبر الماضي
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا بعد قليل
سينظمين من جنيف الدكتور
الايراني اهلا بك ومن بيروت حاضر معنا
كذلك مصفحص الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بكم ضيوفي
الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من بروكسل معك
سيد منى سيد منى بكل هذه الخصائص وخصائص
اخرى لم ياتي على ذكر هذه
الخصوصيه ما الذي يمكن ان تكسب المنطقه
وحتى الثوره الايرانيه ما اصبح يعبر عنها
طبعا بالثوره الايرانيه همم من قوه من
اراده هل مهاب يمكن ان تحمل هذه الثوره
الى مرحله اخرى اكثر تقدما تعتقدين
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين ولازم ايضا
نحيي الشعب الكردي في ايران بالفعل كان
هناك موقف بطولي من من بدايه هذه الثوره
لا ننسى انه على رقم ذكوريه المجتمع
الايراني الكرد وقفوا خلف بنتهم يعني مساء
اميني بقوه على رقم في كثير من القضايا
كان يتم تخلي عن بنات عندما يتعرضنا
لقضايا بالاخص مع شرطه الاخلاق ويتم ملامه
البنت فيها كذا قضايا هو حتى الان يعني
نرى تنظيم جيد جدا من قبل الشعب الكردي
داخل المناطق همم الكرديه وانها طبعا لازم
نعترف انه الشعب الكردي من اكثر الشعوب
سياسيا وتنظيميا في داخل ايران كاخليه
وكما ذكر التقرير بالفعل الاول جمهوريه
كانت جمهوريه مهاب وبعد الثوره
الخمينيه همم كانت كردستان من مناطق
المنتفظه وبقيه منتفضه ومتمرده عام من بعد
ثوره وكانت حاضنه لكثير من الاحزاب
المعارضه الايرانيه لذلك لها تاريخ همم
يقدم له هذه الرمزيه همم ثانيا التنظيمات
اللي موجوده فيها والاتحاد اللي موجود في
تلك المناطق لان احنا نرى هناك اتحاد بين
حتى التجار يعني كل التجار المهابات اخلاق
ومحلاتهم هذا يدل همم الاتحاد جيد طبقات
مختلفه من الشعب في العدد اتجاه اخذ شريحه
ينظمون لهذه الاحتجاجات والاخيره انه على
رقم كل محاولات نظام الايراني
بالتهام همم الانفصاليين او بالانفصال انه
هناك تعطر كبير في كل مناطق الايرانيه
وانا ارى انه الكردستان ممكن ان تحمل عالم
التغيير الجيد في ايران السيد مصطفى بكل
هذه الخصوصيات وبكل ما نق وهو خاصه فدخل
الايراني بخصوص الاقراض همم البعض يقول
بان حتى الحرس الثوري يحسب 1000 حساب
للاكراد ان خرجوا وان واصلوا خروجهم
وتظاهراتهم هل تعتقد بان الفرق يمكن ان
ياتي من مهابات
المساله الكرديه هي مساله 100 سنه منذ
مؤتمر روزان الى الان هناك مساله كرديه
همم
تعيشها هذه المنطقه هناك ظلم لم يحصل لم
يستطيع همم الشعب الشعوب الشعب الكردي في
الدول الاربعه من انزلاق حق تقرير المصير
او عندك كل خلل السياسي في اي دوله مركزيه
من ايران وتركيا عراق وسوريا تعود همم
نشاهد تعويما جديدا للمساله الكرديه همم
العقل النظام الايراني البهلوي الولائي
كان دائما يعتبر الازمه الكرديه الازمه
رخوه سلبيه ورخوه ايجابيه سلبيه انه ممكن
ان تكون امتدادا اقليميه اي انها كره
تتوسع فلذلك الانظمه الاربعه تتفق عليها
ويعتقد في عقله الامني البهلوي انا عندما
تقنع الاكراد تستطيع اعاده التثبي سلطتك
المركزيه كما قالت الضيفه الكريمه هناك
حياه سياسيه مبكرا لدى الاكراد الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني مرحله رضا بهلوي
مرحله محمد رضا بهلوي المرحله الخمينيه
والان المرحله
الخامنائيه وصعودا وهبوطا في المساله
التركيه الكرديه ما يحاول النظام فعلها
الان في يريد يريد قمع كل الاكراد لانه
يريد ان يعيد الاستقرار لما يسميه الحواف
القوميه او الاثنيه او يعني العلاقه
المركز والاطراف في في ايران كما ان البعد
الكردي ياخذ بعدا قوميه فهو قد يثير
القوميات المركزيه في ايران مع العلم ان
الاكراد في مظاهراتهم وفي حركتهم
الاحتجاجيه لم يرفعوا الاشعار من الفرنسيه
ولا حقا في تقرير
المصير بل على العكس كانت شعاراتهم وطنيه
تمتد من الاقواس الى الى اقليم كرد الى
الى المناطق خلينا نسالهم بطريقه مباشره
صحيح ولكن خلينا نفهم باننا نسالهم بطريقه
مباشره حتى نفهم هذه المطالب وما الذي
يوده الاكراد من هذه المظاهرات صار جاهز
معنا ضيفنا من جنيف الدكتور علم الاجتماع
والناشط الكرسي الايراني دكتور ببان اهلا
بك معنا ما الذي يوده الاكراد من هذه
الاحتجاجات من هذه المظاهرات نحن تبعنا في
الواقع في مختلف المناطق الايرانيه الاخرى
هناك شعارات رفعت تطالب حتى باسقاط النظام
هناك حتى من رفع شعار الموت للديكتاتور هل
الاكراد يتفقون مع هذه الشعارات هذه
المتفتات هل لكم مطالب خاصه بكم في هذه
المرحله بالتحديد
اب في تصور
كل الاعظاب الكرديه
شعارهم هو ااا
سيستم فيدرالي التحدي في ايران مع شعوب
الاخرى ساكنين في ايران يعني اكلات في
ايران هم همم
هم همم
[موسيقى]
يناازلون
كراسي ديمقراطي في ايران وهمم في نفس همم
انتم ترونها من نافذه الحكم الذاتي
نعم نعم في في اطار الايران ااا
يكون هناك ديمو كراسي الديمقراطي اه
والشعوب في ايران
كرد عرب
ازاري وبالوجو اخرى
ممكن
تعايش معا في ايران ولكن يبدو هذا طموح
طموح كبير مع ما يحصل اليوم لا اقصد كبير
في مضمونه ولكن المرحله هل تساعد هذه
المرحله على الدفع بها هكذا همم طموح
دكتور يعني همم
الفكره موجوده ولكن هل المرحله تطيح
وتساعد على الدفع بها تعتقد
في ايران في هذا المرحله هما
يحاولون ينزلون من اصل من اجل اسقاط
الحكومه حكومه الاسلاميه في ايران
متى مطالبهم نفس المطالب في
مدون اخرى كتكهران
وبالجستان وفي همم
اهواز الاكات في في هذا المرحله همم لا
يطلبون متعلب همم
هويتينيه ثم ك همم باقي شعوب الايراني
يحاولون من اجله همم
استاذ منى همم هل تعتقدين بانه وجود
الاقراض في مثل هكذا مظاهره همم استمثال
عائله همم
اشارتي منذ قليل همم في مقابل ما ينتظره
البعض من المزيد من التجديد والقمع من
جانب النظام المعادله كيف ستكون في الايام
القادمه في هذا الايطار
اولا حساب متابعتنا لوضع الايرانيه النظام
حاول ان يقسم حتى المدن الى مناطق مهمه
والمناطق غير مهمه نحنا لدينا تقريبا 11
مليون يعيشون في الضواحي المدن الضواحي
الفقيره بالعاده حسب تقسيمات المدنيه
الايرانيه هاي المناطق غير مهمه حتى لو
انتفضت تماما فهل حافظوا على مراكز المدن
كذلك ام قاموا بطاقه تقسيم المحافظات
الايرانيه يعني مثلا لا من السهول جدا قمع
كردستان او بلوشستان هؤلاء من السهوله
ممكن ان يسمع ليه باقي المناطق الايراني
في تويتر مؤخرا له عملته تغريده قال فيه
لازم انت همم نقوم بتقديم المساعدات
الكامل لمزارعين في اسمهان بسبب المشاكل
المياه والجفاف يعني بما معنى هو في خطاب
اخر هدد ما لهوشستان ولكن في خطاب هو الان
يحاول ان يقدم وعود لمناطق غير يعني
بالنسبه لنظام جمهوريه الاسلاميه الحفاظ
على مراكز المدن والحفاظ على المناطق
المركزيه مهمه جدا لانه كما الروايه
السوريه ايضا تنمو بالتدمير مناطق
الهامشيه على رقم انتفاضتها ولكن حافظوا
على مراكز المدن مع الاسف نرى انه تطبيق
نفس السنار يقام بهجوم عسكري تام في منطقه
كردستان يعني دخلوا بدبابات ومروحيات لانه
يسهل دائما قمع مناطق الاخليات هم اخليها
اقليه دينيه ولكن هناك تعاطف كبير من
المناطق الايرانيه الاخرى نتمنى اسقاط
النظام قبل ما يقومون بتطبيق نفس السناريو
همم فيران كمان انه احب اقول يعني افعال
كثيرا في مناطق الهامشيه اللي احنا نتكلم
في ازمه الخبز ولكن احنا لا نسمع فيها
لانه حافظ على تقديم ال المؤن في مناطق
المركزيه في المدن فاهل المدن ما زالوا لم
يشعروا في ازمه الاقتصاديه كما شعره فيها
المناطق الهامشيه هل تعتقد سيد مصطفى بانه
هذه الطريقه التي ينتجها النظام الايراني
في محاوله على الاقل ابقاء على مراكز
المدن في محاوله همم فتح ملفات تبدو بسيطه
اقتصاديه او ماليه همم حياتيه همم
هل يمكن ان تبطئ هذه المظاهرات هل يمكن ان
تخمد هذه الاحتجاجات ام ان الاوضاع قد
فلتت
اعتقد ان الاوضاع قد فلتت النظام الايراني
يذهب الى كردستان لانه يتجنب المواجهه مع
الاداريين لانها ستكون مكلفه جدا لذلك
يتعامل مع الاقليه الاضعف باعتبار الاكراد
انفصاليين ويستطيع ان يحرض المدن المركزيه
او القوميات المركزيه ضد ضد الاكراد ولكن
ما نشهده في الساحه الايرانيه ما قاله
ضيفه الكرام عن ان وحده الشعارات لم نرى
في مظاهره في كردستان احد يرفع العلم
الكردي الخاص بالشعوب بالشعب الكردي وهذا
دلاله نضج لدى المتظاهرين لدى المحتجين
لذلك النظام في مازق هذه العمليه ويتحول
الى قوه الاحتلال عندما تنسحب القوات
وزاره الداخليه ويدخل قوه عسكريه كالحرس
او مستقبلا كالجيش في علاقه مباشره مع مع
الشعب في يرحم حاله من الاصطدام وعدم
الثقه لذلك هو الاحتلال الان في في محافظه
المركزيه اخرى
نعم نعم
ولكن ما الذي تقصده بحديثك عن عجز النظام
يعني كيف تفسر انت همم هذا العجوز لماذا
لم يتمكن هذا النظام الايراني الذي تمكن
سابقا من قبل احتجاجات تمكنه من ايجاد
حلول ولو مؤقته وتمكنا بقمعه كما يقول
داخل الايراني من اخماد هذه المظاهرات كيف
تفسر هذا العرس في هذا المرحله
العجز مبني على عده عوامل اولا هذه
العمليه الامنيه الثانيه او الساعه والاكل
يعني والافراط في استخدام القوه من شهر
حاول النظام غطاه السيد الخامنئي في خطابه
هو فشل خلال اسبوع الان العمليه الهوائيه
افراد في استخدام القوه العجز لما قالته
السيده ان عندما يقف الكردي بكل ذكوريه
المجتمع الايراني خلف حقوق المراه عندما
عندما يواجه النظام الايراني بادوات بكل
ادواته الامنيه والعسكريه والقمريه فكره
الموضوع المراه فهو يواجه العائله باسرها
ولا يستطيع افراد العائله الا ان يدافعوا
عن بناتهم
وابنائهم لذلك اصبحت العمليه ليست ليست
بالمعنى حتى تظاهر الفردي المطلبي الحركه
السياسيه حركه طلابيه بالعكس هي تحولت الى
حركه اجتماعيه تواجه عمق النظام
يفتقد الادوات الاجتماعيه يفقد الادوات
الاقتصاديه وخ طب وغير مقنع لكل الشعوب
الايرانيه لذلك الشعوب الايرانيه توحدت
حول شعار اجتمعت حول الشعارات موحده في كل
المدن الايرانيه وفي كل الساحات هذا هذه
الشعارات لا يملك النظام القدره او على
على حلها او الاجابه عليها او او حتى
احتوائها لذلك ذهب بغرورها الاستراتيجي
بمعنى انه مستعد ان يحتل المدن الكرديه
ومستقبلا المدن البلوشيه الى ان يصل الى
الحذر الكبير في المناطق الاداريه التي
ستكلفه كثيرا كدوله مركزيه الان يحاول مع
الاكراد
الازمه مع الاكراد التي لم يحسبها ان هناك
في العالم في اوروبا او في المجتمع الدولي
في خلال 100 سنه في قضيتين العباده
الارمنيه والمساله الكرديه التعامل مع
الاكراد سيزيد الضغط الدول الراي العام
الاوروبي لما لهم الاولمبيات كرديه في
الخارج كما ان سيقول اقليات الاخرى في
ايران هلا الصمود كما صمد
الاكراد الاقل الذي يعتبرون خاسر رخوه ليه
ويستطيع النظام قمعهم دائما لذلك المساله
في تداعيتها خطيره على النظام لذلك هو
يعزز م- يزيد من مازقه في هذه اللحظه
والمشكله انه تعامل في 2019 بالقوه
المفرطه في مقابل ازمه معيشيه الان هي
هناك ضرب لجوهر النظام من خلال الاسره
الايرانيه او اسره الشعوب الايرانيه التي
تتحدى كل مبادئ النظام وهو في جماعه عاجل
عن الحل او عن الاجاره
هذه الحسابات الدوليه ورغم هذا الصمود
سواء من عموم الايرانيين او كذلك من افراد
ايران همم الا انه في المقابل النظام
الايراني يشن حمله قمع يقول البعض قد تشتد
في قدم الايام هناك حديث عن رصد مسيرات
ايرانيه سماء ما هباد وهناك كذلك حتى
وكاله الاخبار الفرنسيه همم تشير الى
اعدام سادس اعتقد او سبع همم وبالتالي ما
الذي يمكن ان يقدمه الاقراض لقضيتهم انتم
مستعدون للذهاب الى اي درجه من التضحيات
[تصفيق]
هناك اجواء همم الحرب في بعض المدن في
كردستان الايراني كان مهابات
وساقس هناك همم
مروحيات هناك مسيرات فوق المدن همم
في تصوري همم
[موسيقى]
حكومه يحاول همم تحويل الانصار من همم
مظاهرات في مدن اخرى همم
كردستان همم
نفس همم احنا همم
ما نريد همم
[موسيقى]
لا يريدون حتى تشون بالضبط حتى تعكر اكثر
ااا طريقه تعاملها مع الهاتف المظاهرات
صحيح صحيح بس في نفس الوقت نحنا نعرف
حكومه همم
يواجه اكلات مع كل اساليبها قامه هذا هذا
هذا في نفس همم
نعرف ان همم بالنسبه للحكومه همم احزاب
الكرديه هم همم ممكن همم يكونون المحرك
لتوحيد همم
[موسيقى]
نبقى في متابعه كل هذه التطورات اكتفي
معكم حتى الان بهذا القدر على ان نلتقي في
حلقات الاخرى شكرا جزيلا شكرا
ياسر استاذه في علم الاجتماع والنشط
الكردي والايراني شكرا لك من بروكسل شكر
الجزيل لك مناسلاويه الباحثه في الشان
الايراني وشكرا كذلك لضيفنا من بيروت
مصطفى فحص الكاتب الصحفي شكرا جزيلا